le bâtiment est si vieux que les cinq
salles d'opérations ont dû être fermées
à plusieurs reprises souvent la
climatisation faisait défaut et l'an
dernier la présence de chauve-souris
avait forcé l'arrêt des chirurgies on
constate on n'est pas capable de
maintenir les activités dans ce bloc là
puis le rénover coûterait beaucoup trop
cher
il a donc fallu construire en 24 mois un
tout nouveau bloc opératoire un
partenariat public privé le partenaire
privé actuellement offre l'environnement
physique s'occupe également de l'hygiène
et la salubrité du lieu puis pour le
reste tout le reste est assumé par
dessus l'entreprise qui a construit le
bâtiment loue l'espace au secteur public
qui fait travailler son propre personnel
les corridors sont larges et baignés de
lumière naturelle on retrouve ici cette
salle de chirurgie deux de plus que dans
l'ancien pavillon
Mélanie Morin qui a subi la première de
deux opérations dans l'ancien bâtiment
Vitus est impressionné
que l'hôpital est un petit peu plus âgé
qu'ici
c'est vraiment plus beau ici
c'est blanc et les patients comme
Mélanie ont accès à des salles
d'opération haut de gamme le rétinologue
Flavio rezendé l'opèrent à nouveau mais
cette fois dans les nouvelles
installations elles permettront aux
chirurgien d'enseigner en direct à des
collègues de l'étranger on a bâti le
réseau de internet informatique dans le
bloc opératoire pour pouvoir faire des
conférences à distance live sur le web
pour faire de l'enseignement pendant des
chirurgies une bonne nouvelle pour
l'enseignement et le rayonnement
international de Maisonneuve-Rosemont
des installations qui vont aussi
permettre d'attirer et de retenir le
personnel un défi majeur dans l'est de
Montréal on a la meilleure structure
pour amener pas juste d'infirmière des
nouvelles recrues à toute tout le monde
qui ont un vrai engager maintenant ça
devrait être plus facile
et effectivement pour une rare froide
dans l'est de Montréal on rencontre des
infirmières comblées après 18 ans dans
le vieux pavillon Sandra Tremblay était
pâtée
dans nos espaces puis c'est vraiment
waouh
[Musique]
ici David gentil les réseaux Canada
Montréal